Baldwin der bei Filmaufnahmen
versehentlich seine Kamera Frau
erschossen hat hat in der Nacht sein
erstes Fernsehinterview gegeben er hat
wirklich verwunderlich es gesagt und er
hat geweint
[Musik]
wir möchten Sie sorgfältig so weiter
eine surface mit Vertrag
dort eingeliefert seines die für Geld
ja das hast du das große Interview mit
George stephanopoulos Alec Baldwin sagt
er hat nicht abgedrückt schon jetzt noch
mal an was wir über die dramatischen
Ereignisse in Santa Fe Wissen
der Polizeiruf nach dem Tod von Alec
Baldwin zeigt die ganze Dramatik der
unfassbaren Tragödie
am 21 October erschießt Schauspieler
Alec Baldwin versehentlich bei den
Dreharbeiten zu dem Western Rast eine
Kamera Frau mit einem Revolver der
eigentlich eine sichere Requisite sein
sollte doch die war für die der
Regieassistent dem Schauspieler in die
Hand gibt ist mit scharfer Munition
geladen einen Tag nach der Tragödie wird
die Tonaufnahme des Notrufs im Internet
veröffentlicht zuhören ist wie eine Frau
mit einer Mitarbeiterin des Notrufs 911
spricht mehreren Berichten zufolge
handelt es sich dabei um Drehbuchautoren
Mimi Mitchell
dann wird es dramatische die Anruferin
streitet sich mit einer anderen Person
am Filmset dabei fallen knallharte
Anschuldigungen und Schimpfworte Alec
Baldwin ist nach dem Unglück am Boden
zerstört er verschanzt sich mit seiner
Frau und den sechs gemeinsamen Kindern
in Manchester einer Stadt im
US-Bundesstaat Vermont mehrere
Mitglieder der Filmcrew reichen
Zivilklage gegen den Schauspieler ein
darunter auch die Autoren Mimi Mitchell
ihr Vorwurf der Todesschuss hätte gar
nicht im Drehbuch gestanden
noch immer wird ermittelt wie die
scharfe Munition ans Set kam eine der
Theorien besagt dass für einen
vorherigen Film Schach für Munition für
Waffen Trainings geordert wurde diese
Patronen könnten ans Set von Rast
gelangt sein
[Musik]
er hat dass das Protokoll des tro
todesdrama es um die kamera Frau Halina
hat Jens und darüber wollen wir jetzt
sprechen und vor allem natürlich über
das aktuelle Interview von Alec Baldwin
mit unserer Show Chefin Janina Kirsch
Hallo Janina guten Morgen wie hat Alec
Baldwin denn in dem Interview auf dich
gewirkt
zerstört zerstört also man sieht ihm
natürlich an dass er nicht gut mit
dieser Situation klarkommt was für jeden
natürlich verständlich ist
ihnen so auch in Tränen ausbrechen zu
sehen das geht einem natürlich nah auf
der anderen Seite war ich doch stark
verwundert über die Aussage ich habe den
Abzug nicht gedrückt weil natürlich die
jeder sich jetzt die Frage stellt wie
kann es denn dann passieren weil er
würde sonst noch mal ins Gedächtnis
rufen er hat geprobt er hat einen eine
Bewegung geprobt wie man den Colt aus
der aus der aus der Tasche zieht oder
aus dem aus dem Halfter und dann quasi
zieht so das heißt diese Bewegung hat
stattgefunden und sagt er gedrückt hat
er aber nicht
ich bin keine waffenexperten deswegen
kann ich mir das auch schwer erklären
wie dann sich ein Schuss lösen kann aber
das ist natürlich eine eine eine große
Frage die geklärt werden muss und ich
vermisse noch so ein bisschen die Ruhe
also ich frage mich wird ja auch ganz
klar gefragt wie viel Geld also fühlst
du schuld das sieht man jetzt noch nicht
das wird dann heute Nacht zu sehen sein
wir gucken das natürlich auch alles aber
diesen Aspekt der Reue auf dem bin ich
sehr gespannt er hat sich ja schon mit
der Familie auch der Kamera Frau
getroffen und hat danach ja auch in
einem Interview gesagt dass es ihm sehr
leid tut hattest du da auch nicht das
Gefühl dass er Reue im Herr gut dass ein
das leid tun muss das ist ja klar mir
geht es um den Aspekt dass er ja nicht
nur Schauspieler war und er derjenige
war der die Waffe in der Hand hatte
sondern er ist auch Produzent des Films
gewesen deswegen kriegt er noch mal eine
ganz ganz andere Verantwortung für all
das was passiert ist wir auch tragen
müsste wenn er nicht gewesen wäre der
die Waffe in der Hand gehabt hat also
auch dann hätte er würde er die
Verantwortung tragen und die große Frage
wie sind diese Patronen diese wie es
diese scharfe Munition in diese Waffe
gekommen und wie ist es überhaupt ist
die überhaupt unset gekommen die muss er
mit aufklären denn er ist als Produzent
dafür mitverantwortlich
versehentlich nur etwa ein Ausschnitt
ein Trailer ein sogenannter den wir
gesehen haben für dieses Interview
George stephanopoulos der NK von ABC dem
amerikanischen Sender wo es ausgestrahlt
wird hat hinterher gesagt dass er das
Emotionalste Interview gewesen dass er
je geführt habe und sein Gefühl sei
gewesen dass Alec Baldwin extrem ehrlich
gewesen sein diesen Interview das ist
natürlich
aufheben
ist interessant finde ich das wird sie
jetzt gestern Abend auf gekommen ist und
zwar es in dem amerikanischen Berichte
Medien berichtet worden dass es eine
neue Spur gibt und zwar soll es einen
Requisiten Lieferanten gegeben haben der
angeblich schon mal mit Patronen
gehandelt hat die mal echte Patronen
waren die dann verbraucht wurden und die
man dann durch cycled hat also das man
in diese Hülsen quasi neues Pulver rein
getan hat um diese dann wieder zu finden
und in diesen Untersuchungsbericht das
läuft laufen ja jetzt seit Wochen
Ermittlung ist wohl dieser Name dieses
Requisiten Lieferanten gefallen also gab
es einen Durchsuchungsbefehl und dieser
Lieferant wurde quasi durchsucht und
auch befragt das Ergebnis davon steht
noch aus also es könnte noch ein neuer
Spieler auf Spielfeld kommen mit dieser
Firma die sozusagen diese möglicherweise
diese Patronen geliefert hat gab ja auch
vor kurzem erst diese Pressekonferenz
über die wir ja auch live bei Bild
berichtet haben das kam also davon gab's
aber bisher noch nicht nichts Neues
wieder dass man da noch mal genauere
Details zu den Ermittlungen bekommen hat
richtig nee noch nicht dass es das was
jetzt noch aufgekommen ist das sozusagen
diese dieser Requisiten Lieferer ins
Spiel gekommen ist und man den genau
unter die Lupe genommen hat
möglicherweise so wird es in der
amerikanischen Presse ausgedrückt ist
das die Quelle für die scharfe Munition
wir haben ja aber auch Alec Baldwin
gerade gehört der ganz klar sagt er kann
es sehen sich selber nicht erklären und
eigentlich hätte diese Munition gar
nicht auf dem Grundstück sein dürfen
also auch er wirkt sehr überfordert und
sehr überfragt
heute Nacht morgen früh werden wir
klarer sehen und natürlich wieder
darüber berichten du wirst wieder hier
sein Studio Janina vielen Dank für den
Moment